let's bring in Republican Congressman
Michael Waltz of Florida he's a member
of the House armed services committee
sir it's tempting to focus in all this
on how this combustible economic picture
is going to play out in the midterms but
I think the more important thing to
drill down on you first here is how this
is playing out in the American people's
daily lives now many months into this
inflation crisis I know that in parts of
your District Americans are still now in
the wake of the storm without basic
electricity services
yeah so we're seeing guys gas prices
tick back up Biden's strategy frankly of
working reaching out to dictatorships
Venezuela Iran which has 50 million
barrels that they're trying to sell as
part of the uh Iran deal and others uh
it just isn't working and now we have
OPEC restricting Supply the thing that's
so frustrating I think to all of us is
that it right here under the ground in
the United States of America we have oil
and cleaner gas than Russian gas or
others ready to go Not only would it
help Americans at the pump uh but it's
the biggest driver of inflation because
everything has to be transported but the
other piece is on foreign policy Russia
has invaded Putin has invaded its
neighbors every time it was Cash flush
because of the high price of oil in 08
with Georgia and 14 with Ukraine and
then again uh this year when oil was
over a hundred dollars a barrel
Biden could starve Putin's war machine
right now but unleashing oil and gas and
they keep telling this fiction that our
oil and gas or domestic oil and gas
companies they keep pointing to these uh
these leases that they're supposedly not
taking advantage of it's because the
administration isn't giving the permits
to actually take advantage of them so
he's misleading the American people it's
hurting the American people in their
wallet and it's keeping Putin cash flush
so that he can uh continue this invasion
so where you are the search for
survivors is still underway now in the
aftermath of the hurricane at least 84
people are confirmed dead the majority
of those victims are in areas of Florida
that have been effectively flattened
decimated and as the state is looking to
recover and rebuild the governor Ron
DeSantis is now ringing alarm Bells
about a whole new challenge take a
listen to this
we've had four looters that were
arrested uh I guess a couple days ago
and and they need to be brought to
Justice and we're not going to tolerate
it but you know three of the four
are illegal aliens they're illegally in
our country and not only that they try
to loot and ransack after in the
aftermath of a natural disaster
well President Biden is slated to meet
with the governor later this afternoon
the two publicly at least setting aside
their political differences over the
past week to kick-start this much needed
relief effort Congressman my question
for you is is there an aspect or an area
of American life now that is not touched
by the border crisis
yeah I mean that's that's a great
question I think we would struggle to
find one when I reach out to Veterans uh
who aren't getting the services they
need teachers whose schools are are
already uh crowded hospitals uh that
can't provide all the services that they
want to There's an opportunity cost uh
to American citizens when we have two
million people a year and that's not
even counting the godaways that are
flowing across uh our border that's
eight million people just uh on Biden's
first term that are taking services that
others uh may need and that that aren't
appropriately getting so there
absolutely is a cost in every aspect of
life I do want to say you know I do
appreciate the Biden Administration
giving the major disaster declaration to
the counties that need it but there is
going to be a lot of follow-up it will
be from the Department of Agriculture
for our crops Department of
Transportation for our infrastructure
there's still going to be a lot of work
to do to work cover from this storm and
I do expect both of them will see any
differences aside just as they did after
the Surfside condo collapse a few years
ago well the White House Press Secretary
Kareem Jean-Pierre and FEMA's
administrator have both tried to clarify
and defend the vice president's comments
earlier in the week about Hurricane
Relief being based on Equity at least
under the Biden administration's
approach now Transportation secretary
Pete butterjudge says this take a listen
we've got to make sure that we're
helping everybody based on the need that
is there that it's fair that it's
Equitable and there are some folks who
see politics where it doesn't need to be
in the end I think you do need to help
everybody based on their need now if
your vacation home got damaged that's
probably having a different effect on
your life than if you're only home got
damaged
a Washington examiner opinion piece out
today argues this take a look Kamala
Harris's Prejudice could dissuade people
from seeking needed hurricane Aid
um first of all do you agree with that
and second of all is there room for you
know addressing the neediest
and including equity in the way you roll
out these funds or do we got to choose
yeah that's that's the whole problem
with viewing the world through the lens
of uh race or through the lens of
people's skin color number one this is
this is not the time uh we're all coming
together as Americans uh in our
communities as neighbors uh and and
we're helping each other out as fellow
as fellow citizens period I mean that
really should be uh the extent of it and
there are rules in place for example uh
if you're applying for certain types of
Aid uh then and you are demonstrating an
additional need or you didn't have
insurance uh then those rules are in
place and that'll be taken into account
I think this is virtue signaling at its
worst and it's it's um it's blowing back
on them because they're just exposing
this wrong-headed view of the world that
the progressive left uh keeps keeps
putting forward whether it's in our
military or whether it's how we help
people in the wake of a disaster
I want to make sure we get into this
with you real quick before we let you go
your Republican colleagues in the house
are vowing to investigate Hunter Biden's
foreign business dealings even further
if they take back control of Congress in
November they say they're still on
earthing new texts and emails and
evidence in the president's son
capitalizing on his father's position
back when he was VP now Hunter's former
business partner is coming forward again
he talked exclusively last night to
Tucker Carlson take a listen
subsequent to the election he's now the
sitting president of the United States
but there are hundreds of data points
that Joe Biden was acting in
uh in a capitalistic term I would say
the chairman the chairman serves a
purpose right he's a figurehead he shows
up in meetings shakes hands advises you
know has faith in his team effectively
that was Joe Biden's role in the Biden
family business ventures and around the
world and not just my Venture I met with
him multiple times
so that's what Bob olinsky says take a
listen to the president back in 2020 on
the campaign Trail
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses do you stand
by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
um I should point out the bobolinski
last night
um whether you find him credible or not
sir said that uh Jim and Hunter Biden
stood to profit to the tune of not
Millions not tens of millions but
actually hundreds of millions of dollars
what do you make of all this yeah the
the Chinese Communist Party have a a
theory uh they have a Doctrine that's
called Elite capture and that is to
capture and and basically corrupt key
elements of an adversary society and
when it comes uh to major political
figures they don't go after the
principle they go after the Suns they
call it the princelings uh and it this
is absolutely Falls in line uh with that
um with that kind of theory from the
Chinese Communist party we need to get
to the bottom of it we know that Hunter
is an equity holder for example amongst
other things of a Chinese nuclear uh
suppliers group company that is
blacklisted for trying to steal American
Warhead technology I mean there are so
many things we have to get to the bottom
of but the thing that's so disturbing is
that the FBI did nothing about it they
say they have a non-interference policy
in the run-up to election but doing
nothing is also political interference
and that they've done nothing from then
until now is further eroding our trust
in the FBI and the doj we got to leave
it there Congressman thanks for taking
time out uh for us this morning and I
wish you the best going forward with
recovery there in your district and
across the entire State obviously you
get you bet I win or Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now